про електронний кабінет підприємства
Скажіть будь ласка нам ще цього не
вистачало наші нещасні ці підприємці які
ще жеврюють якось мало того що їх тут
штурмують і влаштували Гетьманщину проти
них мало того що закручують гайки
податки хабарі давайте ще їх
зобов'язжемо мати ці електронні кабінети
окремо вести на кожного ну це Друзі Ну
це зайва вся абсолютна історія ну нащо
ви взяли хорошу ідею хороший закон і
напхали туди ну всього підряд що тепер
Це все виглядає ну ну вже ну знаєте Не
так як воно мало би бути друзі не
підтримуйте це ну давайте хоч покращимо
цей закон не голосуйте в одному екстазі
з опзж